it was recently announced nick that
ariana is now coming she's going to take
your seat next season so here's the
reason why i asked what do you have wait
a minute exactly wait exactly it's just
this season so like here's my question
though do you have any advice for her
uh no i mean ariana as we all know is
one of the best singers in the game and
she's going to be an incredible coach
uh i i think the only advice i would
give is just not to trust any one of you
we've been feeding her lots of
useful advice yeah i'm sure very useful
yes yeah uh but she's gonna kill it
she'll be great yeah um i thought yeah
you could at least warn her about the
one she's probably gonna sit next to
might be nice all of you she watches the
show though she knows
she knows about blake
she does watch the show everybody knows
about blake yeah everybody knows lies
and deception
i just hope i don't step on her look at
her she looks a tiny on there
the height differential between the two
of you will be substantial wow i really
hope she's sitting right next to you
it'll just look amazing
so wait are y'all scared of ariana yes i
am too i'm terrified somebody literally
asked us in the interviews yesterday we
were going together and they said what
do you think about arianna i was like i
think this is my last chance to win
i was like ariana has a
huge fan base and they are fervent
and
if they show up to vote we're all in
trouble 100 percent are you scared at
all
now what i'm not afraid of her fan base
where that look at look at me where's
the camera bring her ariana fan bring it
on i'm not afraid
they pay me to win
oh my gosh ariana fans
is that you guys
are how silent you are
[Music]
you